chacun va pouvoir me défier à un truc ça
j'adore ça je lai voilà vous avez appris
que pour le défier d'accord ok ça sera
et ça sera à paris sur une semaine où
vous doublez votre salaire ou vous
perdez votre sac est ok ça vous voilà à
ce que vous voulez vous c'est quoi
couleur de cheveux ouais non au foot
foot au foot ouais j'ai une tension
assez fulgurant dans le foot allez si
vous voulez vous c'est quoi on mettrait
une cage en salle futsal deux équipes
d'accord je fais mon équipier bikes à
fond de la toile a
donc adressé presse et voilà c'est fait
ça ne fait pas vraiment qu'il voulait
il m'appelait grisonne j'ai regardé page
parce que j'embarque août l'équipe de
france
[Rires]
ça devrait être kenny va se retrouver
avec alexandre guerrier à
face à gries mode
saas estimé par une ascension fulgurante
vous allez voir vous allez voir le signe
d une descente fut quand
je vois le tennis j'arrête parce que ça
a été un fiasco pour moi donc je vais
tenter la dictée en grec en
mer le pas
il faut un truc un peu c'est c'est un
défi
c'est celui qui a le moins de fautes
gaga ni l'accord
j'anticipais choisi un nom belle
histoire
si on n'entend pas pour la notation
[Applaudissements]
ne sera pas bon parce que ce sera pas si
tu peux choisir le texte de mon choix
demain dans nos noms alors le texte
choisi veut le voir au dernier moment on
dirait le sexe au dernier moment parce
que vous êtes vous à des magouilles et
les deux ne doit pas servir pas de
problème une dictée quelqu'un de votre
équipe me donnera là que j'assurais la
dictée ok ok moi la meilleure
pissaladière dacquois puisse à la gueule
alors cessé rien faire en cuisine je
sais avec qui tu es tu crois vraiment
que j'étais une pissaladière
mais il avait
perdu
sur à jour bien beau de dire
si elle bat non seulement je double mon
salaire je me fait circoncire une
deuxième fois
exactement mon lit je m'en charge non
merci c'est bon c'est bon c'est fait la
malaisie râler c'est fait c'est qu'on
ait jamais joué de ma vie maintenant
et je ne la donnerai
c'est comme ça
comme ça de loin à l'entraînement avant
jc jusqu'à si j'ai le droit de montrer
nettement non pas bien sûr là bas si
vous voyez quoi vous allez faire des
dictées par mounier sur elle à toutes
les vacances
et on pouvait se dire ah bah ouais là
les nerfs ils étaient
ils étaient 12 pour rentrer à la maison
quelles étaient leurs intentions
gilles alors c'est un défi un peu
cérébrale à vous proposer alors non il
est malin il est malin et physique en
même temps c'est quoi on choisit une
date où vous êtes libres parce que moi
je suis tout le temps libre on la fixe à
l'avance on invite tous les deux fatto à
dîner et on voit avec quelle choisi
d'aller dîner ok c'est bon il est alors
ça fait beaucoup de peine
[Applaudissements]
la grèce
refus de la mairie c'est quoi l'histoire
ou draguer pas tous n'ont pas n'ont pas
draguer l'invité à dîner on lui fait des
propositions d'invitation a dit nos
restaurants d'accord on voit si c'est
vous ou moi qui gagne on peut partir on
ne jette tout ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avec la terre dit d'accord magnifique
cette saleté bronzette ça me fait
beaucoup de peine je suis pas sûr de
permettre aux consignes mexes et
débarrasse de sa mère
pas sûr de ce que voulait lâcher pas
tous nos de trouver d'autres moyens
alors moi je vous propose un concours de
décapsulage de bouteilles avec chaque
partie du corps et chaque objet que l'on
charge auprès à l'aller porte la trace
et plus encore peut-être ça c'est mon
choisy des parties du corps on se
souvient des objets oui on s'est mis
d'accord et ensuite on fait le con
kouassi qui ont des capsules
c'est le seul truc là où je me dis
attention n'était pas encore à moins de
filles ccca si je viens
vous ouais dans la patronne
c'est quoi alors j'hésite entre essayer
de le mois voire possiblement
détiendrait un face à face au poker
d'accord pas mal pas mal ou si vous
préférez
un petit trois rounds de boxe allés tous
les deux je prends les deux fois les
devants alors par contre si vous perdez
c'est un an de salaire en poussins
s'entraînent tous les matins là bas les
six pieds pour je me suis toujours actif
oui je me suis toujours entraîné mais
conserve une aura couvert et pluvieux
alors je vais vous dire moi je
m'entraîne en pieds poings bon d'accord
au ballon des poings ya deux ans vous
l'avez quand même cassé les points
d'accord c'est sûr et certain balle je
n'ouvre jamais être sûr qu'on fait trop
froid on ne voulait pas faire plutôt
qu'un nom me 3,3 en pieds poings pieds
poings accord en trois mois avec plaisir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je dois taper partout
ah non mais bercy a les coucougnettes
non non et il vole genou et alors ils
jouent subventionner cette poule
mouillée de talleyrand dans le vestiaire
validera la taille à investir dans le
vestiaire et mon neveu qui était la
pomme temps cependant je suis ta box et
tout l'apport
et sajoo et les buttes à jouer debout
dans le vestiaire balasy première heure
il est chaud il a dit daniel j on
[Applaudissements]
le fera sûr et certain le france poker
aussi un peu bloqués au caire mais point
vous êtes entraîné un pompier point que
alors quand je fais un peu les pieds
mais beaucoup les points d'accord il
aura pas tendance était très dark à
l'émission on peut faire tout ça demain
ouais bah on adapte il ya pas mal de
temps perdu moi j'ai pas le temps de
m'entraîner moitié dans le seul truc
auquel tout est la faute des capulet est
ce que je suis je suis nul je suis nul à
ça même un cadre et des captures avec
pas le faire donc imaginé avec mes
fesses
tiens
donc comme saâdane après la dictée moi
je vais proposer un truc halak est avec
lequel parfois vous avez du mal avec moi
c'est quoi c'est le lancer de téléphone
faut arriver jusqu'au bout
à chaque fois je te kiffe qui est une
équipe qui fait donc là cette fois je
lançais téléphone hu est arrivé tout le
monde
tu m'a cassé les couilles il arrête de
me parler nodyna tétouan bordel
je la danse et à la musique il m'a fait
chier
avec trois nouveaux téléphones
très cher là n'ont alors pas le mien
donnez moi un nokia 32 10 heures
avec la chaîne cette médaille on va
jouer notre salaire aujourd'hui d'accord
avec asie si vous gagnez jo double
salaire si vous perdez vous êtes à 0 ok
elle est partie en deux points à l'aller
aller loin d'aller relever tout cas le
cabinet a prêté son talent je vais un
bélier suivre un jerry sloan on me
répétait il va pas sur l'échangé qui
avait envoyé les dauphins le nul du nord
c'est pas mal hein c'est pas bien de sa
vie et des krachs un
blackhawk à l'aller gymnase et non merci
alors j'ai toujours été galons les
femmes commencent à l'eva les redhawks
elle décide alors j'ai pas de téléphone
je vais prendre une battue a bien nous
l'avait promis à l'union m'est égal la
paix soleil
les gaffes et les enfants adorent aller
sauver les 102 points en deux mois
[Applaudissements]
c'est injouable
puissants du jour sert de base c'est ce
qu'on avait dans les mains
allez
[Applaudissements]
à quoi
traiter la gonorrhée son labo c'est un
poids attention
[Applaudissements]
oh
bush et ça
les règles sont claires j'ai touché avec
la voulait
alors ajouté
s'il a quelque chose qui touche un seul
s'est fait éliminer j'y crois et je suis
gentil je vous le vermont fermé
[Applaudissements]
ça touche quelque chose si oui
les rêves sont claires
règlementaires
si on fait un effort dans deux mines
balala
aleri on est à un partout à vous de voir
c'est quoi je n'ai même pas besoin de
jouer pas ça ira chez gagner moi elle
est passée à huy elle a parqué géraldine
cayla important apprécie pas d'accord
sur le coup de l'obstacle alors le décor
non non il serait toujours été touché ah
oui là là là nul c'est annulé un jour
dieu ce sera pareil pour moi je fermerai
ma gueule sauf que ça n'a pas été le cas
pour toi à quoi bah oui non mais moi
parce que moi j'ai pas touché j'ai fait
j'ai bien volleyé touchés alors valérie
oui ya ce vice de procédure chez aso n'y
a aucun vice de comparaison à la même
coque oui à la même adhérence je
conseille de le faire tous les 200 cac
pour être quitte à ok
on invitera les jb naim ça va jouer
maintenant vous enlevez les coques ont
marre des bricoles ouais et on enlève le
slip qu'elle me
[Rires]
rappelle qu'à jésus qui nous attend
quand même ah oui et c'est moi qui
recommencent à la wii bas alors t'es
gentil ni
l'âge moyen des préleveurs comme ça je
n'ai pas la paix le caire attend je fais
là mais ces gens qui portent une fois
mes toiles à l'asie
attention
là la
mécanique saine
alimentation place que ce sens comme été
touché une pression
bonjour pour ça valérie j'ai une
question à vous poser
est ce que vous voulez une règle à la
con choix quitte enfin qu est ce que
vous voulez que je tire ont-elles et que
vous perdez vous peut-être votre salaire
aujourd'hui vous le doublé s'ils jouent
bas non je vous laisse trois secondes
pour réfléchir
donc donc soit soit jeudi on arrête tout
et là j'ai rien perdu à gâteaux etc
jouent soit je joue et je perds en
sachant que vous avez fait sept mois je
préfère une petite chienne teamteam perd
sur un petit tiers moi je pense que tu
devrais te vide n'y va pas s'il vous
plaît
les conseilleurs ne sont pas les payer
ouais surtout de langon après comme je
n'ai pas joué lors de leurs mots c'est
pas non plus un truc non mais énormément
non mais quand même oui mais comme je
perds beaucoup comme un bon match je
peux faire maintenant parce
qu'une chose que le partage moi c'est
pas ça
[Rires]
même par ce ballon vous me proposez pas
alors je me sens fébrile ouais un peu
tes vous verrez quand je vais jouer
je pense qu'ils bluffent il est sûr et
oui mais non on est sérieux toi tu es un
mélange d'émotions très fortes à ce jeu
va gmail à soyaux j'étais
assez c'est parce que alors je vous dis
pour assigner devant halla halla suis là
pour rejoindre i télé free la douce et
j'aimerais donc j'ai pas regardé la
taille et à la taille est la même voilà
pourquoi j'ai un petit comme ça moi
d'accord merci au caire
elle est punie même prix je remercie
mais vous savez quoi
j'ai envie de dire que le public s'amuse
déjà environ
si je répète j'aurais spectre avec un
petit chapeau qui chapeaute aussi je
perds un euro chacun
arbon valérie kiffer le bon ménage
[Rires]
aulas
le cinéma du gard
à les regarder
avec
photo j en quoi
loi à
fabas
à
m
quoi
les doigts
[Applaudissements]
le govic vous avez choisi votre torche
au niveau des médailles c'est dommage
car si je gagnais gens voyaient toutes
uniques en voyage
[Applaudissements]
et
voilà
[Applaudissements]
il obtint
[Rires]
ces gloires à gaza voilà mon petit bal à
vous garder deux ans oui je garde le
grison
est comme keen'v je garde le sourire
après il va dire qu'il ya des trucs
tabou
[Applaudissements]
la démo m'a soit parce que c'est rendu
mes actions
il
bien sûr comme ça vous êtes des moteurs
mais pas du tout
qu'est ce que ça va être la présente
innocent
le
crb tessala vous avez triché remettez le
bien avec beinheim
des grands moteurs est unanime à tous et
on la refait mal tiré tous les doutes
n'ont
même pas lui tenir ma nouvelle mais pas
d'échec hadj
jésus nous attend
dans ses yeux qui nous avons l'eau se
calque des amis un pastis et on refuse
de partie
laissait you know what you pay to play
parce que c'est chez moi 40 et je sais
moi
et moi c'est moi qui ai inventé ce jeu
là notre cher que genève et zurich il
est historique
il est tombé là il était là
mais non mais mais le nahd sommaire du
tout dit pas de bêtise non mais c'est le
non
mais les règles sont très claires
lorsque c'est un rat qui tombe la partie
est annulé quand c'est un demain le coup
il valide
[Applaudissements]
je triche et les je peux vous dire
quelque chose tout à l'heure qu'est ce
qui s'est passé benhalima retirer oui
c'est vrai ouais ouais donc ça va moi je
ne retiens plaît pas et en plus je lis
j'aurais pas dû retirer parce que mon
cou était extraordinaire à la la
qu'est-ce que tu es généreux
rester généreux je vous laisse yonne
naoui à faire ce genre de choses le
public et des anneaux d'enfant du tout
pas du tout fait ou ne fait pas du tout
non pas déçu un modèle non
est ce que m
[Applaudissements]
est ce que ben ali va retirer oui
le mari dans la rue que se faire de
sarenza gay une
[Rires]
et
[Applaudissements]
là je vais vous dire quelque chose
d'ailleurs vous avoir pensé benhalima
n'était pas là mais c'est pas vrai vous
mentez quoi là-bas si vous montez
pousser vos soupes et poussez vous
douter et ce qui me plaît et là je vais
faire un coup et je ne viens pas qu
aucune réclamation à d'accord allez s'il
vous plaît benhaim a lancé son téléphone
elle a lancé jusqu'ici super yoplait
souple est ici
je l'abats elle ne sera pas payé ce soir
ainsi elle gagne elle sera payée double
mais si j'ai pas payé je peux pas parler
aussi bien sûr vous parlerez est plus
que d'entendement
aller en effet après il va dire que des
machins là ça va être chaud
des soussous
médaille
casablanca
maroc
luna est ce qu'elle dit fan ou non
d'accord très bien
super on regarde à deux fois
x men prochaine avec toute la famille
le docteur a dit que tout allait très
bien
[Applaudissements]
koné lassiné
tout d'abord à une faillite
esaïe avec ceresoli
d'un cadeau tequilla d'un cadeau cadeaux
bien cadeaux emprunte au
centre toi tu vas dire que
attention vous êtes assez entraînés
pendant la pub merci qui est bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]